impeachment for that the word
impeachment is thrown around a lot in
American politics here's a brief
breakdown of what it means and how it
works on a basic level it's when
lawmakers accused a senior official of
doing something seriously wrong I did
not have sexual relations without asking
the president Ukraine to take actions
which would benefit him politically when
directed by President Nixon to fire the
prosecutor investigating Watergate that
senior officials usually eat the
president's the idea of impeachment is
to see whether or not that person should
be removed from office so how does it
work well once someone starts the
process I'm announcing the House of
Representatives will be forward with an
official impeachment inquiry the house
then has to vote on whether or not to go
ahead more than half of the members have
to vote in favor of it for something to
happen but the person who's impeached
doesn't necessarily lose their job you
only have to look at Bill Clinton in
1999 concede that he carried on as
president for a year after it's the next
bit that would remove a president from
office if the house fails to perceive
then a trial is held in the Senate the
Chief Justice of the Supreme Court runs
that trial but it needs a two-thirds
majority chicken bit that's tricky right
now because the Senate is controlled by
Donald Trump's own party the Republicans
if the president is convicted then the
vice president takes over for the rest
of the term but the ousted president
won't face jail they'll just be given
their marching orders if the president
isn't convictable then they just carry
on as they were in fact no president has
ever been booted out through impeachment
only three got closed Nixon Clinton and
Johnson so the likelihood of America's
needed getting many PO is pretty low one
thing is for certain though it's
complicated it's lengthy and it's very
divisive